if we decrypt the protection on this
disk
we might be able to take down the entire
spy ring
this is why we need you show us those
skills
so
hell yeah that's it you did it bill
now that we got what we need we can
safely move on audrey
[Music]
so
all right i'll let mason and woods know
that we're ready
they'll be handling this one our source
tells us that aldrich is about to move
south across colorado and into northern
new mexico
that's where we'll intercept his convoy
we can't let a former cia operative run
a person's spot factory
let's put this [ __ ] six feet under
[Music]
i can't believe alders betrayed the
c.i.a betrayed the whole [ __ ] country
phoenix 2-4 this is phoenix 2-1 30
seconds out
we're up mason locked and loaded
[ __ ] think they can hide from us
time to send a message
aldridge is in one of those trucks we
hit the ground hot
watch for runners overwatch
let's go
[Music]
so
thank you
jesus
jason follow me 2-1 you got eyes on the
target
through that gas station it's gotta be
aldridge move up to the gas station
what's up
oh
someone on the roof
or on the roof
keep moving let's go
oh
foreign
happy
[Music]
thank you
uh
come on
she's finished let's get a picture of
aldridge
for the cia family photo
for the traitor section you know the
shitty part
got the photo all right let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
[Music]
heavy fire wave
myself
here
with you guys
[Music]
it's hot down there
faster
um
foreign
splunk
[Applause]
geniuses
[Music]
uh